last week during one of Germany's most
prestigious award ceremonies literally
this was like their equivalent of the
Oscars a Ryan Gosling impersonator was
able to trick the show's producers into
presenting him with an award for Lowell
and this producer showed up I mean it's
what lookalike showed up and had them
convinced it was him and they gave him
an award take a look this really
happened
[Applause]
I'm Ryan Gosling dedicate this award to
Yoko and jars that's amazing
they say he got away because he showed
up at the last minute and they thought
oh you know mr. Gosling must be alone
backstage so he just came out there and
I think I look more like Ryan Gosling
well apparently it was an elaborate
prank and the guy spent weeks planning
it now of course I've had Ryan Gosling
on this show many many times he always
seemed very nice okay but watching that
clip I have to tell you made me question
whether or not maybe I could have been
fooled as well so I went back and I
looked at some of the interviews I've
done maybe it's possible take a look
please welcome Ryan
[Applause]
Brian
[Applause]
you know we're gonna talk about gangster
squad now you excited about this a lot
of people gonna be seeing this is vegan
gangster squad opens in theaters
tomorrow Ryan Gosling
my favorite part my favorite part of
that as the dog shows his clip and then
the crowd reacts to the clip and he's
like he turns like yes it's a very fine
clip
you